he's an entrepreneur motivational
speaker television personality and
author he turned down a career in
accounting to focus on sales and now
teaches others the art of selling he's
the author of five books and has hit the
New York Times and Wall Street Journal
bestseller lists
he's Grant Cardone and here his top ten
rules for success hey I want to talk to
you today about success success duty
obligation responsibility if you
approach it any other way which most
people are most people think well I'll
be successful if the economy works I'll
be successful if something happens I'll
be successful if I win the lottery
ticket look you're not going to be
successful if you don't demand it if you
literally don't stake a claim to it and
say this is mine it's important you're
not going to have it I promise you I
know I'm telling you from experience I
spent the first 25 years of my life like
like a spectator watching other people
get successful and then wondering why
was it success is your duty it is your
obligation and your responsibility
almost 90% of sales managers say they
don't have truck time you know and again
it goes back to look if you knew it was
going to bank you money today would you
make time for it so they would they
would make time for because they'd make
time for the things that make the money
if you if you have a customer hopefully
if you have a customer and you're
working to deal with that customer and
you got a hamburger in front of you
hopefully you're going to push the
hamburger aside and work that deal
because the priority is to make money on
in the same in the same conversation
that sales manager does not believe that
a sales training converts to ROI or
money so he doesn't make the time for me
when you say you don't have time if the
truth is you're saying I'm not making it
a priority because I don't think it
makes me money so look you want to get
your work ethic so high that people
actually admire you I'm going to ask you
a question right now do people know you
because of your unbelievable work ethic
if you can't answer yes to that man
you're not going to get in that top 10%
you got to get at the top you people
have to know you not because he's a good
salesman oh he's a good dish oh he's an
artist
so he's a good pianist oh he's a he
writes a great you know story no did
people need to know you for one major
thing first he works he produces the
guys there every day the guys pushing
and shoving because the truth is no
matter how good your ideas are how good
your art is or how good your skill set
is if you're not working man if you're
not vibrating in a frequency that people
say my god how does that guy do all that
if you're not vibrating at that rate 10x
levels massive action tremendous work
ethic that's just a muscle nowness it's
just a discipline in your life and it's
a way it's a normal way that other
people think is abnormal ryan seacrest
Tom Cruise Oprah Steven Spielberg Donald
Trump still pumping and working as a
billionaire look if you're not working
at that level you're not going to make
it get your work ethic in man it's the
American Way work ethic check it out the
biggest struggle man was just getting
around other people that would say I can
do it I mean that's the biggest struggle
just you get around one guy says yeah
you can do it and then you talk to him
tomorrow and he's like now it is
freaking you can't do this yet you know
there's so few people telling you to do
it you know what there is a lot of save
your money
protect yourself conserve don't spin
don't take risk taking risk is the new
way to be risk adverse so where's the
biggest struggle for me was my family
man the people closest to me was the
biggest struggle every time I went out
to do another deal everybody told me you
don't need to do that man
the only person that was encouraging me
was my twin brother because I would see
how he was doing it dude he was making
his swings and so every time I'd get
around other people so I'll tell you a
little trick I did on weekends I would
always go see Holmes I couldn't afford
that has always inspired me I would go
look I would go drive neighborhoods
literally I've done this my entire life
until I finally got to the point where
they wouldn't even let me in the
neighborhood there's neighborhoods in
Miami do you can't even go see you can
they won't even let you in the gates
most of you can get in if you know some
of my tricks so the point that show Vita
is writing on the board right now is you
got fuel in your tank
it wants to be accelerated on and
you got somebody in the backseat saying
hey be careful nobody likes a backseat
driver okay so they're sitting there
they're putting they're putting mental
pressure on the brakes when you're
trying to accelerate the negativity is
just negative and there's no money in it
there's no future and being negative
where's the solution you know I can't do
that we can't do that that can't happen
this is wrong that's wrong
oh my gosh taxes are too high taxes are
too dude it's negative it is negative it
is negative look there's so much
abundance and negativity that by itself
tells you what there's no value in it
you got to make a commitment to service
you got to make a commitment to like hey
I have a target I know that when we
don't achieve targets here in my office
the first thing I ask regardless the
internet department if it's my
accounting department on collections or
it's my sales department I'm going to
ask a question what is the target
no target results in no sales so if
you're in parts if you're in service
look have a target measure that target
hourly if you really want to get results
measure your target every hour to see
what do we get in the last 60 minutes I
promise you do those two simple things
don't even learn anything about how to
sell anybody anything have a target
measure it every hour and I guarantee
your sales will come up within any
company I have owned I have four and
five flows in every company I don't have
one flow I'm not going to depend on one
product once I get those four streams
coming in from one company okay for
instance at this company it's a it's an
online project called Cardone University
then their speaking gigs then there's
books then there's audios there's mp3s
those are flows coming in for one
company at some point I'm like okay
let's do a second deal so I'm going to
then have a company that runs parallel
like a skier right I don't want the skis
crossing over I want them to be parallel
so that anything that maybe I can't do
any longer in this company maybe I'm
going to outsource to a partner and
build a second company then once these
two are skiing along and happy maybe I'm
gonna go do a third company out here
that I have a passion for that has not
thing to do with these first two that is
not diversification that's multiple
strong flows and when I make a bet on
this third company dude I want to take
it I want to take all the money from
these first two flows and I want to say
hey if it's a good deal go all-in if
you're not sure don't put any money in
it at all folks there's so many mistakes
salespeople make I think you need to get
down to light the main ones but you're
not selling the solution I mean that
even before that though I would say
karenins is the biggest mistake people
are not excited they're not alive
they're not they're not showing interest
in the cycle and they lose interest I
was in Barcelona recently and I was
looking at a watch and the cycle didn't
didn't close I could have bought the
watch I was qualified to buy the watch
I'm the one that walked myself in the
shop on my vacation a look at the watch
I know exactly the watch I was looking
for and when I left my wife said what
could he have done to close the sale I
said well he could have kept life in the
cycle he could have kept the cycle open
so what I mean by that is look if you're
not interested if you don't believe the
cycle can be closed it will not close so
the number one mistake I think
salespeople managers and the store makes
is they assume a closed can't be had
that day I go into every cycle every
sales cycle with every prospect every
phone call every no matter how complex
the sale is or how simple it is with the
belief that I can sell that product that
day this time now a work to your
potential not your quota if you want to
stay really motivated if you want to
answer the question to why people that
have already made it keep pushing it is
because they don't operate on quotas
they operate off potential they're
driven to reach their potential this is
also tied to their ethical obligation
they know what they're capable of
nobody can tell you what you're capable
of you're the only one that knows okay
so work to your potential not your quota
quotas are numbers who made them up some
guy says okay your quota is blah blah
okay
based on what how do you come up with
that quota he only picked that quota
that number
because he thinks is significant are
compared to other people maybe in your
industry
look don't operate on quotas you want
them clearly you want them but you want
to be driven to reach your potential not
just some number some mechanics hey my
potential I know nobody else knows it I
know what it is you know yours
work to your potential not just a quota
and I promise you you will be on fire
day and night
hey Grant Cardone I just want to give
you a little encouragement here on
Thursday afternoon this week I have been
in Detroit Buffalo New York City I was
on my way to Hartford it got canceled
because of some situations well I just
dropped my back why am I telling you all
this okay
now I came to the wrong terminal I'm
gonna walk back to - I'm not asking to
feel sorry for me I'm doing this as an
encouragement video dude things don't go
right you got to push harder you got to
spend money that you didn't think you
were going to spend hang in there
don't quit do not quit push okay I know
how hard it is I know it's hard I know
there's moments where everybody thinks
oh my god what am i doing just keep
pushing your family needs you to do it
you need you to do it god bless america
definitely need you to do it so hang in
there keep pushing when you think about
quitting just understand that everybody
you compete with is having the very same
thought last-man-standing baby man
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because Chris Waller asked me
to so there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave it in
the comments below and I'll see what I
can do and I'd also love to know which
of grants ten rules most apply to you
and you're going to go and take action
on them leave it in the comments I'm
going to join in the discussion thank
you so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon